I'M USUALLY ON EVERY LIST.
IT DOESN'T SHOCK ME.
JONATHAN TURLEY, THANK YOU.
HERE NOW WITH MUCH MORE, RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, OHIO CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN.
YOUR INVESTIGATION IS INTO
WHETHER OR NOT THE FBI HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED AND WHETHER OR NOT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WEAPONIZED.
WE HAVE THE TWITTER FILES WHERE
ELON MUSK CLEARLY SAID A WEEK
AGO SATURDAY THAT THE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE ATTACK TOOK PLACE
BY THE SUPPRESSION OF
INFORMATION ON TWITTER.
I AGREE WITH HIM.
HE TALKED ABOUT HOW THE MEDIA IS
COME POLICE IT.
AND HOW TWITTER BECAME A
PROPAGANDA ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IF YOU PUT IT TOGETHER WITH WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT HUNTER BIDE B AND
THE LAP TOP.
LOOK AT THE BURESMA DEAL.
YOU HAVE A PROSECUTOR, GETS
FIRED.
SON OF A B, THEY DO IT.
AND TURNS OUT, THE PROSECUTORS
ARE INVESTIGATING THE SON WITH
NO EXPERIENCE BEING PAID
MILLIONS.
WHAT DO YOU CALL THAT?
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
PRESSURE OR SFWIM DAGUES.
-- INTIMIDATION.
NEVER FORGET, SEAN, JIM COMEY
WENT TO NEW YORK TO PRESSURE
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
DOSSIER HE KNEW WAS BALONEY.
IT WAS FALSE.
NOW WE GET THE INTIMIDATION THAT
MR. TURLEY AND YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT COUPLED WITH WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE TO THE
SUPREME COURT OVER THE LAST
YEAR, TRYING TO INTIMIDATE THE
COURT, INTRODUCING LEGISLATION
TO PACK THE COURT.
INTIMIDATION IS HOW THE LEFT
OPERATES.
IT WAS INTIMIDATION AND THE
WHOLE PRESSING BACK AND
SUPPRESSING THIS KEY INFORMATION
JUST DAYS BEFORE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION WE HAVE, THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN THE
FALL OF 2020.
SO, YEAH, WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THIS AND HOW POLITICAL THAT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BECOME.
>> HANNITY: BUT IT GETS DEEPER
BECAUSE THE FBI HAD HUNTER'S LAP
TOP SINCE DECEMBER OF 2019.
>> YEP.
>> HANNITY: OKAY, THEN WE HEAD
TO THE ELECTION OF 2020.
THEY KNEW THAT THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THIS, IN FACT, WOULD BE
MADE PUBLIC WAS REAL.
AND WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE FBI
MEETING WEEKLY WITH EVERY BIG
TECH COMPANY WARNING THEM THAT
THIS TYPE OF STORY ABOUT HUNTER,
ACCORDING TO ROTH, MIGHT COME
OUT AND YOU MAY NOT WANT TO
DISSEMINATE FALSE INFORMATION.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME THE FBI
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN DARN WELL BY
THAT POINT, 11 MONTHS LATER,
THAT LAPTOP WAS REAL.
THEY'RE TELLING BIG TECH TO BE
ON THE LOOKOUT BECAUSE IT'S
PROBABLY FALSE.
IT TURNS OUT THEY DID INTIMIDATE
EVERY BIG TECH COMPANY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TERMS OF
PUTTING THE THUMB OF THE SCALES
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION?
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
BY TELLING BIG TECH TO LOOK OUT
FOR A RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
OPERATION, IT'S ALL PART OF
THEIR INFORMATION OPERATION.
THE 51 GUYS WHO SIGNED THE
LETTER, WAS JIM BAKER TALKING TO
THEM?
HE HAD TO KNOW MANY OF THOSE
GUYS WHEN HE SERVED AS CHIEF
COUNSEL OF THE FBI.
HE HAD TO WORK WITH THOSE GUYS
WHEN HE WAS SPYING ON TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN AND TAKING INFORMATION
FROM HILLARY'S LAWYER, MR.
SUSSMAN.
WHEN HE WENT TO TWITTER, WAS HE
WORKING WITH THOSE GUYS?
DID HE PARTICIPATE IN DRAFTING
THAT LETTER OR ENCOURAGE THEM TO
DRAFT THAT LETTER.
YOU HAVE JIM BAKER INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO STOP TRUMP FROM
WINNING IN 2016 AND THERE HE WAS
AT TWITTER PREVENTS THE FROM
WINNING IN 2020.
MAYBE IT WAS JIM BAKER WHO WAS
THE ACTUAL INSURANCE POLICY.
REMEMBER WE SAW THE TEXT
MESSAGES FROM STRUCK AND PAGE.
MAYBE IT WAS JIM BAKER IN 2020
HELPING TWITTER KEEP THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW, BUT WE NEED TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF ALL OF THIS SO
IT NEVER, EVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> HANNITY: DO YOU BELIEVE "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND JONATHAN
TURLEY'S INTERPRETATION OF THIS,
THAT THEY ARE TELEGRAPHING AN
INTIMIDATION CAMPAIGN AGAINST
WITNESSES, AGAINST INVESTIGATORS
LIKE YOURSELF, AGAINST THE MEDIA
IF THEY DARE REPORT ANY OF THOSE
THINGS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS AN
ORGANIZED, WELL ORCHESTRATED,
INTIMIDATION EFFORT TO PROTECT
THE BIDENS?
>> FK OH IT IS.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST STORY.
THERE'S ONE FOUR WEEKS AGO RIGHT
UP TO THE ELECTION.
POLITICO PUTS THE STORY OUT.
DAVID BROCK AND HIS GROUP IS
COMING AFTER ANYONE WHO
INVESTIGATES THE BIDENS.
THEY NOT ONLY TOLD US ONCE, THEY
TOLD US TWICE.
SOMEONE TELLS YOU ONCE, OKAY.
THEY TELL YOU TWICE?
OF COURSE THEY'RE COMING AFTER
FOLKS.
THE FACT IS, WE HAVE THE DUTY TO
DO THE WORK, TO GET THE TRUTH
OUT THERE, TO GET THE FACTS OUT
THERE.
THAT'S STEP ONE IN STOPPING THIS
KIND OF BALONEY FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FUTURE.
WE CAN'T HAVE A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT'S POLITICAL.
DEPARTMENT THAT'S WORKING HAND
IN HAND WITH THE BIGGEST SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO LIMIT WHAT
AMERICANS SEE.
YOU JUST CAN'T.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
AND DO OUR JOB.
>> HANNITY: WHAT DOES IT TELL
YOU, THEY HAD SINCE DECEMBER,
2019 HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP AND
DID NOTHING WITH IT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THE FBI AND THE DOJ AND THE
INVESTIGATION YOU STARTED IN
JANUARY.
>> THE 14 WHISTLEBLOWERS, THE
AGENTS WHO CAME TO TALK TO US
AND TAKEN WHISTLEBLOWER STATUS
THAT THEY'RE RIGHT.
YOU SHOULD BELIEVE THEM.
THEY'RE CREDIBLE GOOD MEN AND
WOMEN WHO TALK TO THEM AND TELL
US HOW CRAZY THINGS ARE THERE.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE AND GET THE FACTS.
>> HAN